-Last time you were here,
you were in a film,
"It Comes at Night,"
which was post-apocalyptic.
-Yeah.
-And we talked about how
you would be, personally,
in a post-apocalyptic situation,
and you said very bad.
-Yeah.
-Now you're in a spy film.
You're playing a CIA agent.
How would you, Joel Edgerton,
be as an actual spy?
-[ Laughs ]
I'd be equally as bad as
my post-apocalyptic --
Well, I was thinking about
it because, you know,
if you're a spy, you can't
really talk about yourself?
-Yeah.
-And the job -- Right?
And you're an actor, it's like,
how am I not supposed to brag?
-Yeah.
No, I think --
Now that you say it,
I don't think we've had
a single spy on the show.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it would be like,
"Are you a spy?"
And I'd be like..."Yeah."
I'm telling you
all the things --
I'm telling you all
the cool things that I've done.
You know?
-Well, you -- Is it true?
I read that you had --
This was something you did have
some curiosity for
when you were younger.
-Oh, I was totally
a spy when I was a kid.
-Yeah.
-'Cause I lived in
a little town called Dural.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I think that's where
all the spies go
when they need
to, like, hide out.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, Dural's,
like, a really tiny town.
But, for some reason,
I had a spy kit.
I had binoculars. I had --
-Had this been
purchased for you
or did you go
out and buy a spy kit?
-No. I don't know where --
I got the binoculars from,
like, a fair.
-Okay.
-They were, like, just
tiny, little binoculars.
I had made a little electronic
bug, like, listening device.
-Oh, wow.
-And I'd hollowed out a book,
and the listening device
I remember using to
listen in to my grandmother,
'cause she was snoring
and she was living
in the room next to me.
So it was like --
Maybe it was, like, a mission
to prove to my mother
that my grandmother was snoring
and that she should
move her to another room.
-So this is some --
-And I successfully
completed that mission.
-Wow. Oh, so you did provide
audio proof to your mother
that your grandmother
was a snorer.
-Yeah. I mean, she's passed away
now, my grandmother.
-Uh-huh.
-I didn't...
[ Laughter ]
-Well, if -- But, again,
as a spy, you couldn't tell us.
-No, I couldn't. No, I wouldn't.
But I'd grab about it if I came
on your show, "theoretically."
-"Theoretically."
-Yeah.
-You have --
There's a scene in the film --
And, like, you, obviously --
Joel Edgerton --
no one would ever
have to do this to you.
Like, you would give up the
information right away.
But in the film, like, they
actually have to, like, strip --
There's a torture scene.
They're, like, stripping away
the skin, your skin.
-Yeah.
-It's very hard to watch.
Was it hard to do?
-No.
-Yeah.
The hardest scenes
to watch for an audience
sometimes are the most fun
things for an actor to do.
I had fun. It was weird.
I spent all day
in my underpants.
Actually, I spend most of
my other days in my underpants,
but I have other stuff
over the top.
Just to be clear.
-This was an
only-underpants situation.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Okay. Gotcha.
-This was an
only-underpants situation.
In makeup, where I was
getting my skin peeled off me --
Not for real,
'cause I'm an actor.
-Right. Of course.
-I have a team of people
protecting me, for real.
[ Both laugh ]
-They'd have to get
through so many people
to actually peel your skin.
-To actually get my skin off?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, but, see,
we have very thin skin.
-Actors.
-Yeah. Wow. This is --
-Very easily hurt.
But I'll tell you something
that happened that day
that was pretty funny, actually.
Jennifer Lawrence...
-Yeah.
-I'm just gonna
pick that one up.
-Oh, you name-dropped?
-Yeah.
She...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, yeah, save it.
Yeah, you don't want to --
Don't let me must
that up for you, yeah.
-She has a little dog
called Pippi.
-Yeah.
-And Pippi's about that big.
And Pippi came
to her rescue that day,
thought she was
really in trouble...
-Oh, wow.
-...and ran onto
the set and was --
And there's a big German guy,
who's torturing us -- or me.
And just decided like,
"This is the guy
who's threatening mom's life.
I'm gonna, like --"
You know, and went at him.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah. Like, this and, you know,
he was -- It was pretty cool.
-So Pippi did
a nice job, ultimately?
-Better job than me.
-It takes a man to say that.
It takes a man to admit that.